throughout history boycotts have played
a decisive role in the struggle against
state oppression the Boston Tea Party
Gandhi's salt march and the isolation of
apartheid South Africa boycotts are a
non-violent way to pressure our
government to change its ways by drawing
attention to oppressive policies through
withholding cooperation and that's
exactly why the Palestinian boycott
divestment and sanctions movement has
been gaining traction worldwide and
particularly on college campuses in the
u.s. i sat down with almond butter booty
one of the founders of the BDS movement
to find out how we got here and why BDS
is so critical to the palestinian quest
for freedom boycott divestment and
sanctions is a movement that was
launched by the absolute majority of
Palestinians in 2005 it calls for
Palestinian rights under international
law at a minimum that means ending
occupation the military occupation of
Gaza and the West Bank including East
Jerusalem ending the system of racial
discrimination that exists in Israel as
I said 60 laws discriminate against the
non-jewish the indigenous population
Palestinians have called for isolating
Israel's regime until it recognizes our
rights under international why is the
Israeli government trying so hard to
discredit and stop us
this rod perceives videos of having a
very serious strategic impact on its
entire regime of oppression because
Israel and as well as we do see the
South African president is very
important we see the u.s. civil rights
movement and the power of boycotts in
that movement in effecting serious
change at academic level the cultural
level and increasingly at the economic
level Israel's isolation is increasing
around the world they see the writing on
the wall and so do we
is that an observable fact that
statement that Israel's isolation is
increasing all over absolutely why else
do you think Israel treats videos as a
strategic threat and allocates hundreds
of millions of dollars to fight the
movement
intelligence services dictating policy
to some governments that they want to
punish BDS activists threatening
churches and trade unions and social
movements and so on pro-israeli US
lawmakers are seeking to criminally
outlaw support for the boycott
divestment sanctions campaign against
Israel if a proposed bipartisan law is
passed backers of BDS could face up to
20 years in prison and a whopping 1
million dollar fine whose day nightís
the United States government obviously
the US Congress are the most complicit
they continue providing Israel with
billions and billions of dollars weapons
protection of the United Nations
preventing any country from taking
serious sanctions against Israel for
decades in one of the most consistent
and steadfast displays of bipartisanship
Democrats and Republicans have United to
guarantee Israel keeps receiving more US
foreign aid than any other country in
the world most of it to fund Israel's
military bringing the total to 38
billion dollars over the next 10 years
without the US government Israel would
face serious sanctions because of its
egregious violations of human rights and
international law so it's not held
according to the same standard any other
state committing equal crimes would be
held accountable but not Israel because
of international complicity the u.s.
claims they're the leaders of the free
world what is it about the u.s. that
specifically prevents them from living
up to that reputation when it comes to
the freedom of Palestinians I wouldn't
even minute put the United States as one
monolithic sum because there's the 1%
and there's the the military-industrial
complex
that's ruling the United States and then
there's the majority of the people in
the United States the majority of the
people have no interest in maintaining
Israel's apartheid the Joseph
to occupation and Israel's violations
recent polls by Brookings Institution
for example have shown that about 60% of
Democrats support sanctions against
Israel 46% of all Americans support
sanctions against Israel that's almost
half this year the New York State Senate
passed a comprehensive legislation to
ban colleges from using state money to
fund any entity that boycotts Israel to
block public funding for student groups
that quote participate in hate speech a
term that they use for BDS and to also
ban the state from contracting with any
organization known to support BDS the
Center for Constitutional Rights refers
to it as the Palestine exception to free
speech why does that exist in the States
for many reasons the most prominent of
which is Israel's Lobby
influence in Congress among elected
officials but Israel can get away with a
lot passing a tiberias legislation
suppressing free speech related to
Palestine and indeed pushing a
McCarthyism of sorts I mean it's even
worse than the first edition of
McCarthyism why is it worth they're
trying to get people who support BDS
imprisoned for 20 years and paying
criminal fines up to 1 million dollars
even during McCarthy's era they did not
have such ridiculous prison terms so
Israel is pushing a mccarthy's agenda
however it's alienating the liberal
mainstream now you have the American
Civil Liberties Union the Center for
Constitutional Rights many liberal
groups around the United States
defending our right to videos while
Saudi Arabia and the United Arab
Emirates regimes have been intensifying
their normalization relations with
Israel especially the United Arab
Emirates which is buying billions of
dollars worth of security equipment from
Israeli companies through u.s.
subsidiaries and the Saudi regime
intensifying its normalization
normalization is also a threat to us to
the Palestinian cause from Qatar from
Jordan Egypt among others but there's a
culprit that's not often mentioned which
the Palestinian official them it has
opened the doors for many Arab regimes
to normalize relations with Israel by
not objecting to that by sometimes
encouraging that so we don't just blame
Arab regimes we also claim the blame the
Palestinian regime the Palestinian
Authority was established in the Austral
agreements as a subcontractor for the
occupation I mean that's a fact it's not
a matter of opinion do you think they
support stability over the freedom of
Palestinian people the states are
certainly normalizing with Israel they
would like nothing more than to see us
disappear of the face of the earth and
to have a normal relationship with
Israel the United States and so on is
that an emotional statement or do you
think that's true well recent recent
developments show that it's not so
emotional after after all with what's
going on in aqsa
Palestinian nonviolent protesters being
shut down by by Israel being shot and
injured and so on we haven't seen any
serious reaction from most Arab
governments especially in the Gulf with
the exception of Kuwait we have not seen
anything a few years ago you would have
heard at least lip service something
condemnation or something now they're
calling on both sides to exercise
restraint what they're acting like
Condoleezza Rice now is just now it does
not create a false equivalency yeah it's
like telling the rapist and the rape
victim exercise restraint it's not just
immoral it's beyond a moral how do you
feel I feel a lot of pain but I'm also
optimistic which is change I mean not
many Palestinians I know are optimistic
I remain optimistic because I'm in the
midst of a struggle and I can see the
results if you see the way Israel
arrests young Palestinian children in
Jerusalem for example and the way they
treat them that torture and so on it's
all meant to destroy them
psychologically not just to colonize
their mind that it's hopeless
the to make them lesser humans that
you're subhuman your relative humans
you're only human in the relative sense
therefore you don't deserve full rights
because you're not a full human after
all as since the neck valve Israel has
not just been colonizing our lands
they've been colonizing our minds with
hopelessness telling us that it's
impossible to resist
we're so powerful you just have to give
up and live as slaves just live with it
so working on hope working on triggering
hope achieving results that give our
people hope it's not just something
symbolic or emotional psychological it's
part of our resistance
[Music]
you